[موسيقى]
نحيكم من جديد الانقسام الذي يضرب جماعه
الاخوان بين قياده لندن واسطنبول على من
يقود الجماعه مستمر لدرجه باتت تهدد
بقائها الجماعه التي انقسمت الى فريقين
يتمسك كل منهما بموقفه تحصرها سيناريوهات
غامضه وفق تقارير اعلاميه فمنضو بدايه
نوفمبر الماضي يتولى محي الدين الزايط
مؤقتا وهو ينتمي الى ما يوصف بجبهه لندن
يتولى منصب القائم باعمال مرشد الاخوان
عقب وفاه ابراهيم منير القائم باعمل مرشد
سابقا فيما سارعت جبهه اسطنبول باعلان
تعيين محمود حسين قائما باعمل المرشد ويرى
مراقبون ان الطيار الثالث او طيار
الكماليين يحاول الاستفاده من الانقسام
بين جبهتين لندن واسطنبول كما يدور الحديث
عن تيار رابع جديد قد ينشق عن مجموعه لندن
في حال عدم تنفيذ مطالبه المرتبطه بترتيب
الاخوان ليس هذا فقط حيث يشير خبراء الى
ان تحكم المصالح الشخصيه في التنظيم
ومحاوله التيارات المتصارعه الحفاظ على
مكتسباتها ضعف من حجم هذه الازمه التي
يصفها البعض بانها غير مسبوقه منذ تاريخه
نشاه التنظيم
انشقاقات جماعه الاخوان بدات الانشقاقات
رسميا في ديسمبر 2021 مع اعلان جبهه
اسطنبول اعفاء ابراهيم منير من مهام
القائم بعمل المرشد العامل الجماعه خلال
الفتره الماضيه زادت وتعمقت الانقسامات
والخلافات ظهور تيارات وجبهات داخل جماعه
الاخوان جبهه اسطنبول بقياده محمود حسين
جبهه لندن بقياده محيي الظاهر تيار الشباب
تيار التغيير انطلق من تركيا
نناقش هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفنا من القاهره
احمد بان الباحث في شؤون الجماعه المتطرفه
ومن تونس الدكتور علي العلانيه الباحث في
شؤون الجماعه المتطرفه كذلك اهلا بكم
ضيوفي الكرام اسمحوا لي ان ابدا من
القاهره مع استاذ احمد في الواقع ونحن
نتابع كل هذه التصريحات
ليست جديده ولكن وكانه هناك تسلسل لمواقف
هناك تسلسل لتصريحات في كل مره تاتي من
جبهه اما من لندن او من اسطنبول او كذلك
حتى من
الداخل داخل الجماعه التقليدي وبالتالي هل
نحن نتحدث عن صراع يعني اقسام او نحن
نتحدث عن بدايه انقسام حقيقي
تحيه لحضرتك في كل الحركات السياسيه
والاجتماعيه والحزبيه تقليديا هناك صراع
او ربما تباين بينما من يسمى بجبهه
المحافظين وجبهه الاصلاحيين على غير
العاده نحن نعيش الان منذ فبراير 2014
تحديدا ومنذ ظهور ما من يسمى بطيار
الكماليون او جناح العمل المسلح داخل
التنظيم في فبراير 2014 على يد دكتور محمد
كمال عضو مكتب الارشاد الذي رفع لواء
العمل المسلح منذ هذا التوقيت تناقض معه
من داخل نفس التيار محمود عزت الذي فضل
استراتيجيه الكمون الطويل في مواجهه
الدوله المصريه نحن لا نتحدث عن صراع بين
اصلاحيين ومحافظين بل نشهد من فبراير 2014
صراع بين ابناء مجموعه واحده او طيار واحد
في البدايه كنا امام محمد كمال عندما
اختفى من المشهد ظهر محمود عزت عندما
اعتقل محمود عزت اله الامور الى طيارين او
مجموعتين تنازع السيطره واداره التنظيم
مجموعه محمود حسين التي اصطلح على تسميتها
اعلاميا بمجموعه اسطنبول ومجموعه ابراهيم
منير التي اصطلح ايضا على تسميتها اعلاميا
بجبهه لندن او مجموعه لندن الان نحن نشهد
انقسام داخل جبهه لندن تحديدا عبر دعاوى
من داخل هذه المجموعه
للحديث عن اصلاح مؤسسي واصلاح لائحي وامور
لا يحتملها اصلا التنظيم المشكوك في شرعيه
من يمثله الان بالنظر الى ان هي كيلو كلها
تضع ضاعت معظم قياداته في السجون من هم
بالخارج ليس لديهم الشرعيه الكافيه او
النمط العضويه الذي يصنع لهم شرعيه يمكن
تسويقها داخل صفوف الجماعه وبالتالي
المشهد مفتوح على مزيد من الانقسامات
بالنظر الى ان الانقسامات الان ليست حول
معنى فكري معين او توجه سياسي بعينه بل
بعد تحول الجماعه الى دولاب مصالح واموال
اصبحنا امام صراع مفتوح على هذه الاموال
وعلى هذه المصالح وهو ما نعيشه الان
وعليه دكتور عليا في فكر الاخوان او في
فكر هذه المجموعات او هذه الحركات
التي تتخذ هكذا شكل وتبنى على هكذا عقيده
هل من السهل حلحله هذه الامور او ان هذه
الانقسامات قد تؤشر الى بدايه النهايه
فعليا
مساء الخير تحيه لكم ولضيفكم الكريم ولكل
الساده المشاهدين اعتقد ان
ان الاخوان يعني في الحقيقه دخلوا منطقه
الزوابع منذ فتره نحن نعرف ان الاخوان
الان عمرهم حوالي القرن يعني 93 سنه ومع
ذلك هذا التنظيم لم يطور فكره ما زال هناك
مجموعات تنتمي الى فكر سيد قطب ومجموعات
فقط يعني تنتمي الى البنا جزئيا رغم ان
انه ليس هناك فرق كبير بين الاثنين
ومجموعات من الشباب تائهه لا تعرفوا اي
فكر يمكن ان يتبع مشكل الاخوان في العالم
العربي وفي منطقه
المهجر خاصه في اسطنبول وفي لندن ان هذا
الخلاف في داخل مجموعه اسطنبول ومجموعه
لندن عكس على التنظيم الدولي وانعكس
بطبيعه الحال على فكر الحركه اذا اصبح فض
الخصومات ياخذ حيزا زمنيا اكبر من تطوير
فكر الحركه والدليل على ذلك ان تنظيم
الاخوان سواء كان الدولي او على مستوى
المحلي لم يعد ورقه وازنه على المستوى
الاقليمي والدولي الاخوان يعني هناك اسباب
جعلت هذه الورقه غير وازنه اخر هذه
الاسباب هي الصراعات على التركه الماليه
للتنظيم لكن هذه الورقه الاخوانيه الغير
وازنه
بالنظرا لعده اسباب السبب الاول لان فكرها
لم يتطور
معناها بالنسبه الى منير قبل وفاته
يعني في جبهه لندن الذي كان يقوم مقام
يعني المرشد العام منير تنبا قبل يعني
يعني وفاته بقليل ان تنظيم
الاخوان سيتجه نحو التطرف اكثر فاكثر اذا
هذا التنظيم الذي بدا يعني افكار متطرفه
في 19 يعني
وحوالي اربعين نجده الى اليوم بعد اكثر من
80 سنه
اتجه نحو التطرف اكثر اذا هذا التنظيم لم
يعد وازنا اذا نظرا لانه لم يتطور في فكره
وثانيا نظرا لان استراتيجيته
التي كان تعول عليها بعض القوه الدوليه
والاقليميه استراتيجيته في مواجهه الانظمه
الحاكمه فشلت ثالثا هذه الورقه غير وازنه
لان تنظيم الاخوان فشل في المهم التي كانت
مناطه بعهدته وهي انجاح تجارب الربيع
العربي
وبالتالي نرى ان هذه التجربه التي كان
يراد منها انشاء ما يسمى
الشرق الاوسط الجديد فشلت ايضا ولكن استاذ
احمد هل تعتقد بان يعني عدم
قدره الاخوان على لملمه صفوفهم او جمع
صفوفهم يعود فقط الى هذه الاسباب اللي هي
اسباب اقتصاديه اسباب محاوله تحقيق مكاسب
عدم تجديد للخطاب ولا الفكر او ان هناك
نقطه اخرى قد يطرحها البعض وهي غياب
القيادات الحقيقيه ليست هناك شخصيات قادره
على الجمع هل هذه النقطه مهمه ام انها
ليست بتلك الاهميه مع كل المتغيرات التي
تعيش الحركه
يعني تاريخيا كانت كان هذا التنظيم يتسم
بمركزيه صارمه وبالتالي دور القيادات مهم
للغايه وربما اداؤه طوال عقود كان مرتبط
بشخصيه القائد المؤسس او شخصيه المرشد
العام في كل الطبعات التي عرفناها سواء
عرفنا نسخه مرشد قوي الشخصيه لديه رؤيه او
مرشد تابع لحلقه ضيقه تدير من خلف
الكواليس في كل الاحوال التنظيم يعني لديه
مشاكل بنيويه منذ البدايه في طبيعه
الاهداف والوظائف التي حددها لنفسه في
طبيعه تجاهله للقوى الاقليميه والدوليه
وعدم قدرته على بناء رؤى استراتيجيه ربما
بشكل من الاشكال اتسم اداؤه طوال عقود
بشكل من اشكال العمى الاستراتيجي هو كان
لديه القدره على ان يفلح تك دون واضح لهذه
استاذ احمد على تجاوز صحيح ولكن هل تعتقد
بانه قادر على تجاوز كل ذلك
انا لا اتصور انا بامكان هذا التنظيم ان
يعوم نفسه لا لدى قواعده ولا لدى حلفاء
الاقليميين في بعض الدول ولا لدى الدول
والاجهزه التي استخدمته بالنظر للضعف
الشديد الذي شاب اداءه خلال العقود خلال
الفتره السابقه حتى ان اقرب حلفاء وهي
تركيا
ذهبت في هذه الورقه ولم تعد تحتسبها ورقه
يمكن ان تلعب بها مع دوله مصر على سبيل
الدكتور عليا في لحظات هل هو قادر على
تجاوز هذه الخلافات بمختلف هذه الجبهات
نعم ام لا
انا في تقديري هو غير قادر والدليل على
ذلك يعني التجارب بحكم الاخوان كانت
ابتسمت بفشل كبير واهم تجربه للاخوان هو
التجربه التونسيه 10 سنوات انتهت المتطرفه
من القاهره احمد بان الباحث في شؤون
الجماعات المتطرفه اعذروني على المقاطعه
انتهت الحلقه السلام عليكم